what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and deck who is finally
back at ua and facing off against
shigaraki's final form the final battle
of mha begins now one for all versus all
for one the most overpowered villain
versus the most overpowered hero and
then the greatest twist of all meteos
shocking super move there is so much to
talk about this was a huge chapter so
let's get into it you guys know how this
works if you enjoy our videos and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now it only
takes you a second but it helps us with
that youtube algorithm and of course if
you haven't subscribed already make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you might think that
subscribing is not a big deal after all
it's free but it actually means a lot on
youtube so i would really appreciate it
finally this video will of course
contain mha manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned now in the previous chapter
shigeraki noticed that he had actually
been accumulating damage during this
fight and that bakugou's new howitzer
impact cluster seemed to have caused
some lasting damage this is certainly a
big deal and a major accomplishment for
the heroes under the circumstances but
we have to remember that all of this
damage is only occurring because
shigaraki's quirks are currently being
erased as soon as he is able to use
super regeneration the damage will once
again become a non-issue at the end of
the previous chapter shigaraki snapped
under the realization that he was
actually being hurt by the heroes and he
then proceeded to unleash a new power a
power that seemed to take his mutation
ability to a whole new level and as that
chapter ended we saw shiguraki's hand
mutations begin to transform into
grotesque copies of his dead family
members the latest chapter begins with
the explanation that tomorrow
shigaraki's perfected body is about to
morph into its optimal shape
as we know even without being able to
use his quirks shigaraki's body has
continued to produce mutations all on
its own and this is what allowed
shigaraki to keep fighting the heroes
even as all his quirks are being erased
by monoma these mutations of course are
a result of his body literally changing
due to the quirk's singularity and in
this chapter shigaraki's body finally
evolves into its ultimate shape as
shigaraki unlocks his final form the
chapter narration confirms that
shigaraki was driven to the very brink
by the heroes and this is what triggered
an even further evolution of his body
this is what initiated his apex form
this form is apparently perfectly
crafted to deal with the threats that
the heroes have been posing to him and
we see that his finger mutations are now
covering his body in a way that makes
them look like armor i have to admit
that this grotesque hand and finger
armor does look kind of cool in its own
creepy and bizarre way
drop me a line down in the comments if
you have an idea of what we should name
shigaraki's final form ultimate
shigaraki perfect shigaraki apex legend
shigaraki anyway on top of these
mutations now covering his body like
armor on his left arm shigaraki now has
a giant mutated hand whose massive
fingers are representations of his dead
family members
you know just in case you didn't think
that his finger mutations were creepy
enough already shigareki then uses this
giant left arm to just toss the heroes
around like ragdolls although ironically
ragdoll is not one of the heroes he
tosses around the heroes he does toss
around are miroko and the big three and
we can tell that they are all in pretty
desperate shape even genus is forced to
leave bakugou's side and enter the
battle but his fiber attacks are simply
not strong enough to contain shigaraki
in his apex legend form poor meteo is
genuinely afraid that this is the end
for him and for all the other heroes
here at ua and he thinks back to the
death of sir nidai and how much sir
naidi believed in him and in his
potential then to make the situation
even more difficult for the heroes
mandalay informs everyone that they need
to lift the electromagnetic barrier that
is currently surrounding the ua for two
seconds now two seconds might not seem
like a long time but when someone is as
strong and as fast as shigaraki two
seconds could be the difference between
success for the heroes and complete
tragic failure within those two seconds
shigaraki could easily escape his
confinement within the ua grounds and he
could then go on to wreck absolute havoc
on all of japan lowering the barrier
even for a moment is a huge risk it
could lead to the deaths of literally
thousands of people and so the already
injured and desperate heroes have to
find some way of distracting shigaraki
long enough for the barrier to be lifted
and then raised again meteo doesn't know
what he can possibly do to get
shigaraki's attention shigaraki is just
so much stronger and he isn't even
bothering to look at meteo so what is
meteo supposed to do to distract this
monster mideo suddenly remembers an
important lesson that sir nidai had
taught him sir knight i told him to
always keep smiling because a society
without cheer and humor will not have a
bright future heroes must be cheerful
and fun because they are role models for
everyone else and in this moment media
knows what he must do
meteo prepares to activate his ultimate
attack the most powerful weapon in his
arsenal it's not his quirk it's not his
physical strength it's not even his
technique or strategy no
no meteo calls out to shigaraki and then
he holds up his butt cheeks and tells
shigaraki to check out this peach
shigeraki is so confused by this that he
does actually lower his guard for a
moment and i mean who can blame him i
think the entire universe was confused
by this master stroke of a move
literally no one was expecting this and
that is kind of the point and then we
finally learned the real reason why the
electric barrier had to be lowered for
those two seconds
deku
is finally here
looking down on the battlefield from
above like some green japanese
spider-man jakku finally returns after
like six months in real world time the
chapter ends as deku enters the ua
grounds and confronts shigaraki face to
face
ladies and gentlemen meteos cheeks
actually saved the day okay okay i know
that some people will not be happy with
meteo's peach scene because it is such a
comical moment that feels like it
probably doesn't belong in such a
serious and consequential fight but you
know what i
actually liked it i'm a big one piece
fan and this is the type of thing that
one piece does kind of all the time and
naruto does it as well actually so i
think that when used in moderation this
type of stuff can actually work i mean
it's funny but it also makes sense since
meteo really was desperate and he
genuinely had no idea what to do in that
moment and what he did do was so insane
and unexpected that it genuinely caught
shigaraki and everyone else by surprise
and that moment of surprise was all the
time that deku needed to enter the
barrier that was the whole point yes
it's a silly moment but it's still way
better than the headshot stuff
especially the headshot bubble incident
from last chapter so you know what guys
i'm giving this a pass meteo is like one
of the best things in mha anyway so
let's just embrace the craziness and
speaking of craziness our boy deku has
returned and not a moment too soon apex
legend shigaraki was about to absolutely
destroy all the heroes at ua and once he
got to aizawa and monoma he would regain
his ability to use all his quirks and
then the game really would have been
over jakku showing up now is the only
thing that gives the heroes a chance to
win although even with deku i don't know
how much they can really do against
shigaraki's final four
i predict that deku is about to unleash
his final quirk very soon because
realistically speaking deku might be
fresh because he wasn't fighting this
whole time but most of the other heroes
on that battlefield are pretty much done
they are injured and worn out and i mean
bakugo literally died at least
clinically before edshaw decided to wish
him back to life with the dragon bubbles
furthermore deku has never faced
shigaraki at this extreme level of power
so deku will need a major power up just
to keep up
and the most obvious power-up will be to
unleash his final quirk and possibly his
strongest quirk the quirk that once
belonged to the second user of one for
all and now this is the million dollar
question what will deku's final quirk be
in the past i talked about the
possibility of it being related to time
like speeding up time or slowing it down
or pausing it for a very short amount or
maybe even being able to increase the
speed at which other things age a
time-based quirk would definitely be
cool to see as part of one for all's
arsenal but now that we know how
shigaraki's crazy mutations work maybe
deku's final quirk should be something
that allows him to tear through all
those mutations more easily like some
sort of blasting quirk what do you guys
think what will daku's final quirk be
and how will he use it in the fight
against shigaraki drop me a line down in
the comments right now
personally i think that deku unleashing
his final quirk will be his next major
power-up but i don't think that this
will be his final power-up i think that
eventually deku will also reach some
sort of quirk singularity similar to
what shigaraki has gone through and once
that happens all of deku's quirks will
blend into one single
ultimate quirk a quirk that might even
end up mutating his body in order to
allow his body to accommodate so much
power again not unlike what happened to
shigeraki but that is just my own
hypothesis we'll have to wait and see
what happens by the way we didn't get a
direct explanation about the end of
chapter 357 when deku and the first
user's vestige saw multiple flying
objects coming towards them but it seems
clear that the flying objects coming
towards him were members of stars and
stripes squadron who decided to stay in
japan and help the japanese heroes fight
the villains it seems that they ended up
giving deku a ride on one of their jets
in order to ensure that he makes it back
on time because we do see those jets up
in the sky as deku makes his epic return
in this chapter so what did you guys
think of this chapter personally i liked
it and it was much much better than the
last few chapters that's for sure and
meteos cheeks did make me laugh so again
like i said i'll give it a pass let me
know what you guys thought down below
and don't forget to leave a like and
comment right now to help us out with
that youtube algorithm if you haven't
subscribed yet make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications you
really have to go through the trouble of
hitting subscribe and then hitting that
notification bell and selecting the
option that says all i know it's
annoying it's a bunch of steps but if
you don't do that you're gonna still
miss a ton of our videos it's just how
youtube works you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys